what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Spider-Man 4 is pretty
close to being in pre-production and it
looks like a big Spider-Man announcement
could be coming pretty soon it also does
look like we could possibly have our
Spider-Man 4 villain or the villain over
the entire new Spider-Man trilogy we
could even be leading back up to another
or I should say a true Sinister Six
movie so lots of fun things to talk
about today plus Marvel Studios is going
to be attending ccxp next month the
Comic-Con experience and it said that
they have a surprise for us for those
who may not have heard it does sound
like Spider-Man and Tom Holland are
specifically going to enter a new deal
for Spider-Man and the MCU actually it's
been said that the Spider-Man deal is
already done but Tom Holland's personal
contract that is the one that we are not
sure is done yet however the new
Spider-Man deal is supposed to be for
six movies in the MCU with the first one
going into pre-production very very soon
we have a new report today and we'll get
right into that but first big thank you
to established titles for sponsoring
this video before we get started big
thank you to established titles for
sponsoring this video this one's
actually really cool and very personal
to me because I've actually used
established titles before my family is
from Scotland and they do a lot of great
work for the environment with
established titles you can officially
become a lord or a lady and when I say
that I literally mean it you can change
your name to Lord or lady and get it on
your credit cards or plane tickets and
you get an official certificate here's
mine in Scotland if you own a piece of
land you are referred to as Lord or lady
through established titles you get one
square foot of land in Scotland which
officially makes you a lord or a lady
and you get a certificate with your
unique plot Number where you can see the
exact location of your land and
something truly great is they plant a
tree with every order and work with
global Charities one tree or plant and
trees for the future to support Global
restoration efforts this makes a perfect
last minute gift for somebody and the
first 200 people purchasing a title pack
using my link will effectively be next
to my plot within a few minutes of
walking distance and depending on how
many of you want to become a lord or
lady we can build our little Cosmic
Wonder Kingdom and right now established
titles is running a massive sale plus if
you use the code Cosmic wonder you get
an additional 10 off so go to
establishtitles.com Cosmic Wonder to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel
so right now we actually kind of know
the release date for Spider-Man 4. it is
not official from Marvel Studios or Sony
but according to thecosmiccircus.com
Spider-Man 4 is set to release on July
12th of 2024 and this does make sense
because Spider-Man 4 is supposed to pick
off where Daredevil born again kind of
leads off it's said that Spider-Man is
going to be dealing with some of the
ramifications of what happens in
Daredevil born again so this release
date would put it right after Daredevil
born again but right before phase six of
the MCU and we know that this needs to
happen because Spider-Man is going to be
a part of the Kang Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars and a lot has to kind of
happen before then some explanations
need to be had about what Spider-Man's
exact position is with the Avengers
right now before he goes on to join them
yet again and this release date lines up
with what we are being told today coming
from the cosmic circus again they are
stating that they have learned that
Spider-Man 4 has now shifted into a more
advanced advanced level of
pre-production an announcement could be
imminent but we'll see if Sony comes
through for ccxp now there are some
things we can expect from ccxp but there
are some things that we should not
expect now according to the same report
from the same person Alex P from the
cosmic circus they say that here are a
couple of interesting tidbits regarding
the upcoming Marvel Studios panel at
ccxb 2022 so this is specifically about
the Marvel Studios panel not about the
Sony panel Alex B tweeted here are a
couple of interesting tidbits regarding
the upcoming Marvel Studios panel at
ccxp22 from what I'm being told the
panel will run for about 45 minutes it
should start around 5 25 to 5 30 Eastern
time and that is PM then the Tweet
continued to say while the panel will
highlight the upcoming release of
Ant-Man and The Wasp quantumania Marvel
will also discuss other projects this
includes Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
but I'm also being told by sources to
expect surprises perhaps a secret
Invasion or Loki update now I would love
to tell you that I think we're going to
be getting a Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 teaser but I don't think that is the
case as at the time CC XP 2022 will
happen Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
will be about six months away that's a
pretty long time ahead to release a
trailer however it does sound like we
are going to be getting a special look
at Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
which does make sense considering that
is the next project coming from Marvel
Studios and it comes out in February we
have the first trailer but we don't have
the full official trailer we've only
gotten the teaser so we are due a full
trailer I would say actually next month
so I would assume and this is just
speculation by my part not confirmed in
any way but I would assume that that's
when we're going to get the full trailer
for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
now as far as Guardians 3 is concerned
they have actually showed footage for it
already they might indeed do the same
thing they showed footage for it at San
Diego Diego Comic-Con this year as well
as d23 at the time when the footage was
shown the footage was not completely
done as far as the VFX were concerned
however it does seem like they have what
they need to do a trailer and what they
showed us for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania at San Diego Comic-Con and
d23 was pretty much what we got for the
trailer that everybody ended up seeing
there were a few slight differences but
for the most part they were the same so
we could probably assume that Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 the footage that we've
seen is indeed going to be the trailer
and it does seem like they have that
done so there is a possibility that we
could get a trailer for Guardians 3 a
very quick little teaser but again I
would not expect that but we should
according to the cosmic circus be
expecting some surprises so it'll be
interesting to see what Marvel Studios
is going to give us now Sony we have
just learned today will not be attending
ccxb so as far as a big Spider-Man
announcement we probably aren't going to
get one because it is usually Sony who
handles the Spider-Man announcements now
the fact that Sony is not going to be
attending ccxp is I should say
interesting it's interesting because in
the past they have used ccxp to show
really really big things but also at the
same time if they wanted to make an
announcement specifically for Spider-Man
and just Spider-Man they might actually
opt to sit out of that and do something
with Marvel Studios and since the cosmic
circus is stating that Spider-Man 4 has
now shifted into a more advanced level
of pre-production that announcement
could be on its way and perhaps this is
why Sony is opting to sit out of ccxp
this year of course there are many
reasons why they would sit out but
considering the fact that a Spider-Man
announcement should be coming soon it
makes you wonder if they are planning
something also not to mention we have
now learned that Tom Holland's
Spider-Man is going to be in Spider-Man
across the spider-verse now we actually
aren't sure what capacity his Spider-Man
is going to be in the film we're
actually not even sure if Tom Holland is
indeed going to be voicing him we've
just learned that it is essentially
going to be the MCU Spider-Man crossing
over into the The Animated Universe
which I think is really cool they've
done things like this before like taking
PS4 Spider-Man the Spider-Man that was
designed just for PS4 and bringing him
into the comics for spider getting this
is a really cool concept and they're
doing it again with the MCU Spider-Man
bringing him into the Animated Universe
again we are not sure about Tom
Holland's contract yet of course we
assume that he is going to be reprising
his role of Spider-Man it would be very
interesting if they simply started over
with a new one I don't think that's
going to happen at all but as soon as we
have more details about Tom Holland and
his contract for Spider-Man we will let
you know but like I mentioned don't get
this confused Marvel and Sony have
already worked out a deal for Spider-Man
the character not Tom Holland the actor
but the character to remain in the MCU
for six more films and recently Vincent
D'Onofrio has expressed that the final
goal for his character Kingpin in the
MCU would be Spider-Man facing off
against Spider-Man that is the dream
goal for his character and we know that
that is most likely going to happen
Kingpin was the villain of Hawkeye then
Kingpin is going to be the villain in
Echo and then again in Daredevil Born
Again these are street level characters
street level stories and that's what
Spider-Man is going to be as well and I
think now that Spider-Man is working
more on a street level and doesn't have
all of the help of the Avengers and all
of the tech of Tony Stark he's going to
be working on that street level a lot
more and it's most likely going to be
running into Kingpin now he's either
going to run into Kingpin in one movie
and face off against him and he's going
to be the villain there or Kingpin could
possibly be the villain over multiple
films which I hope Could Happen Kingpin
could be the villain for Spider-Man 4
then in Spider-Man 5 it could be about
the Venom symbiote but then in the last
Spider-Man film of the trilogy it could
kind of be another Sinister Six film
with Kingpin the Venom symbiote scorpion
who was introduced and we never really
saw anything else from maybe vulture
returns and maybe we get Prowler because
Donald Glover's character was indeed
Prowler who knows but I think this could
be a great build up to a final
Spider-Man movie with Tom Holland
whatever it may be does seem like an
announcement is pretty imminent and it
does look like some big announcements
are coming from Marvel Studios pretty
soon so be sure to subscribe to the
channel and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and for live updates be
sure to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf